how to legally buy properties with no
money
my name's Samuel Leeds I started from
scratch and I built up my portfolio
starting with no money so yes it is
possible this video is supposed to help
people the purpose of this video is for
people who want to buy a property want
to get into investments and haven't got
a lot of money and want to really grow
this is the purpose of the video
sometimes people see what I've done in
property and what I'm teaching and I'm
telling people how they can get started
a very little money and they desperately
try to discredit it and find reasons why
it can't be done if you are the kind of
person that desperately tries to find
reasons why something can't be done
believe me you'll find reasons I mean
generally there's just two types of
people that make it happen people
there's people that find solutions and
then there's make it not happen people
and people that find problems if you're
the latter you may as well stop watching
the video because you're not going to be
successful in this business anyway if
you've got a lot of money it's very easy
to invest in property you can literally
just buy houses you get a passive income
you can pay people to do the work for
you it's really really easy if you
haven't gotten money and you start them
from scratch it's difficult it takes
time it takes effort it takes energy but
even if you've got no money can it be
done absolutely and how do I say that I
said that because I've done that and I
say that because lots and lots of my
students have done that as well so I'm
gonna be giving in this video I don't be
holding nothing back this is probably
gonna be one of the most powerful
informative videos I've ever done so
watch till the end if you're one of the
people don't want to actually do this
because most people say to me they're
like Samuel you can't buy properties
with no money my response is you're
absolutely right you can't I can't
and I just keep continue doing what I'm
doing I'm buying a lot of properties
right now and buying big deals
I've bought small deals I have been
involved in hundreds and hundreds of
property transactions over the last
decades the crazy thing is this most
people that are big-time investors you
know like you look at Robert Kiyosaki
author of Rich Dad Poor Dad Grant
Cardone these people that are multiple
multiple multiple millionaires grant
cons with hundreds of millions on the
multi-millionaire but these guys are
more successful than I am and guess what
they're not using their own money to buy
properties they're buying properties and
getting an infinite return so I want to
use for a few strategies and how you can
do it if you stuck around and you're not
switch the video off yet
it shows me that you're one of the camp
that's a solution find out there's
hungry and it's actually going to do
this so first way is really
straightforward and that's just borrow
other people's money that's it buying
property without using any of your money
that doesn't mean that no money is
involved if you're good at finding
property deals and you can find deals
you can negotiate them you can stack
them the cash flows gray you can just
borrow someone else's money guess what
that's called a no money down deal it's
not no money down but it's no money from
your perspective so that's the first way
when I started out in property bought my
first house I used the bank's money
because when I started it was a little
different you could be very very
leveraged so the banks would lend I mean
in 2000 I started in 2008 but 2007 banks
will lend in hundred-percent mortgages
there's a thousands of people in the UK
that were buying properties 100%
financed by the banks in fact it caused
problems the banks went out of money and
then when the banks ran out of money
they stopped lending altogether and then
suddenly no one was able to buy houses
that's what brought the recession on not
to say that it's necessarily always
smart to buy but to buy properties
without using your money but if you know
how to find the right property then it
is smart because you're buying something
that's appreciating in value that's
producing cashflow and you've not
putting any money yourself
that's smart a lot of people got burned
in 2007 because they were borrowing the
bank's money they'll buying houses to
live in they weren't making any cash
flow
they'll buying in wrong areas that
weren't trending upwards so you can lose
money in property that's the first way
that's what I did starting out board the
banks money then my second property was
really good deal and I borrowed my
grandma's money and listen I'm not from
a wealthy background I don't no one gave
me a penny in terms of Samuel is that
his against a start-up loan the reason
my grandma gave me the money was
genuinely because she wanted the return
on investment she had money in the bank
and I'm not talking big money by the way
first time I borrow money from my
grandma of the color Bob Mary twice was
fifteen thousand pounds so I bought
fifteen thousand pounds which is enough
for me to put down a deposit on a house
and I gave her ten percent return on
investment but then myself the property
was giving me twenty four percent return
on investment the property is producing
twenty four percent return on investment
that means if you put down ten grand you
make in two thousand four hundred a year
that's a calculate so I'm getting twenty
four percent my grandma's getting ten
I'm getting 14% so I'm getting paid more
than shears and she put in 100% of the
money yeah I'm getting paid more on a
monthly basis how is that fair because I
found the deal she put the money in I'm
getting the cabbage depreciation on the
house the house is going up in value on
benefit not my grandma in fact after
four and a half years because I agreed
to pare back after five years by the
time the five years was getting close my
grandma was like Sam you know I want to
have a word about that money that gave
you I'm thinking she's upset with me
because of how much money I've made and
I'm feeling guilty but actually she
wanted to talk to me because she wanted
to extend the agreement why because she
was using the interest that she was
getting fifteen hundred pound a year to
go on a cruise every year and she was
like it's a free cruise my money is not
shrinking me the bank getting a free
cruise Samuel have more money this is
win-win and that's what business is so
when I started out at 17 years old and
broke I wasn't looking for a handout I
wasn't looking to buy property without
using any of my money and scrounge or
get people to feel sorry for me couldn't
have money win-win so thank you grandma
I love you very much thank you for
believing in me and starting me out that
was a normally down deal for me how can
you say that you can't do normally down
deal some of you watching this even well
my grandma wouldn't lend me money we'll
find someone else
I didn't approach my grandma first I was
going on networking events pitching
business people that's one way so borrow
money from the bank borrow money from an
individual basically find good deals and
use someone else's money besides your
own that's called no money down from
your perspective number two Lease Option
agreements now Lease Option agreements
sound a little bit complicated and a lot
of people understand about Lease Option
agreements but don't do them and the
reason they don't do them is because
it's like too theoretical it's too
theoretical but let me tell you
something lease option agreements is how
I started out it was one of the
strategies I used to grow severe wealth
in my property portfolio and here's what
it is lease option agreement is very
simple buy a house now pay for it later
so it's like delayed sale you're not
going to die it by three months usually
the lease option agreement it could be
three five seven years so what I did
when I was starting out was I'd find
properties in trending areas I want to
mean my trending areas is their bottom
out so you predict there's going to be a
capital appreciation you find properties
that are high cash flow properties where
there's landlords or vendors that want
to sell the property for whatever
normally when people are selling a
property they are selling it because
they need the money they are selling
this property to buy this property
they're not the kind of sellers that you
want to speak to in trying to get a
lease option agreement you want to be
looking for sellers whereby they want to
sell the property but they don't need or
can't get the money now what does that
mean that means that they're selling the
property just because they don't want
the property anymore maybe they're tired
of it they're moving away whatever
there's like hundreds of thousands of
properties for sale so you need to find
people that are rather selling it
because they don't need them or they
can't get them on it they're in negative
equity so when they sell it all of the
money that they make they're gonna have
to pay people back that they've borrowed
the money against the property banks or
whoever so when you find people like
that and you say hey look I'll buy the
house off you now I'll pay 100 percent
market value I'll give you exactly what
you want but I'll pay you what you want
but on my terms I'll pay you in seven
years and in the meantime I'll take over
the property take complete control of
the property from their point of view
they don't need their money now anyway
so they're gonna get relief instant
relief of the property and you're going
to take it on but you've not paid them a
penny they've got that and they've got
the price that they want but it's just
been delayed but it doesn't matter
because they don't need that money now
anyway or they can't get it anyway so
that's the person you want to speak to
now from your perspective you take the
property on and guess what you then rent
it out maybe you split it up and turn it
into a hay Chema maybe whatever but you
got to make sure that the property's
cash flowing U+ how much did you put
down nothing you need to put down one
pounds as a transaction fee to make the
contract legal and you need to pay a
solicitor's drop the contracts okay but
maybe you could borrow that money right
from point one tiny tiny weeny bit of
money but here's the thing you get in
cash flow straight away and you've
bought the property and you know the
area's trending so in seven years if the
property's doubled in value or even if
it's just going up by twenty percent who
benefits from that you do that is a
lease option agreement by now pay later
what the government try and get you to
do and what the media and advertisers
try and get you to do is use these
philosophies on buying liabilities like
buy a car on a credit card great
decision right that's what they say but
that's not a great decision because the
car doesn't give you any cash flow and
it depreciates in value the banks will
say by a holiday get
married and put it all on us on the bank
or buy it now and pay for it and these
companies will say buy it now pay for it
later
because they know that will be
attractive for you but the problem is
well the time you come to pay for it
later it's dropped in value and you've
not got any cash flow however this is
why property is so good this is how you
can buy a house starting with no money
you do a lease option agreement you
agreed to buy it for a hundred grand
now it's worth 100 grand but you agreed
to buy it in seven years four hundred
grand after seven years I don't know
maybe it's worth two hundred grand maybe
150 but you have the option regardless
of what the seller if the seller changes
his mind
regardless you had a contract and by the
way I've done a lot of these and I've
had it where the sellers have tried to
pull out at the end of the contract at
the end of the five or seven years and
they can't so I know in the comments
people gonna be saying what happens if
they change their mind they can't so
you've got a really good buy right there
but the question is how can you even pay
for it well how you can pay for it is
for seven years you being in cash flow
what you're going to do with that cash
flow I tell you I'm gonna do with it
you're going to put it aside you're
gonna save it up for the deposit on the
house and then when you buy the house
you've used the money self-funded from
the property and then when you buy it
you couldn't probably instantly
refinance it anyway because after seven
years you buy after seven years probably
gonna need two new carpets a new kitchen
and stuff for seven years is a long time
properties need a bit of facelift every
so often give it a facelift get the
value it to come and look at the
property and say to the value you know
can you smell the paint can you see the
kitchen and then you're gonna refinance
it and it's new current value pull the
money back out and then suddenly you've
recycled the money as well boom shacka
that's the buyer refurbished refinance
strategy combined with lease option
agreement strategy using how much of
your own money nothing what do you need
you need knowledge that's what you need
you need knowledge you need courage just
for the fun of it I do financial freedom
challenges where I start all over again
from scratch starting with no money and
I build up a portfolio from scratch how
using my knowledge that's the thing I
want to pass on I give a lot of money to
charity I have Samuel EADS Foundation
and I've been doing that for years and
years but one of the things I'm most
excited about now is we're building a
school out in Uganda and what why am i
so excited about that because it's
knowledge and that's what I want to pass
on I can give money to people but I'd
rather pass on knowledge same as YouTube
I just want to pass on so much knowledge
because I've done this myself I
physically have done this and I have
been in for a decade there's raising
finance or using other people's money
there's lease option agreement
next I mean you can deal package you can
find good properties if you haven't got
the money you can pass them on to
someone else and take a broker fee and
then with that fee what are you going to
do with it charge you if you average of
fees 3000 pounds do it five times that's
15,000 pounds put that towards a deposit
on your own house this is a really
powerful one now there's joint venture
Inc because but you know what people say
and it freaks me out it's always broke
minded people and usually broke minded
people are also broke people they have
no money
broke minded people are people that try
and find reasons as to why they can't do
something technically because people say
I'll but what about the legal fees oh
but what about the pound it's like come
on get real what about the pound I could
literally say to you right now I am
gonna give you a free house come to
London come to my house I'll pay for the
legal paperwork and I'll sign over a
house to you for free
earn income but no mortgage it's yours
and some people could say it's not free
though is it cuz I've got to get to
London I've got to pay the petrol money
I'm trying to give people an opportunity
to get started from scratch or from as
close to scratch as possible you got a
few thousand in the back right what do
we know because I'll tell you what most
people are saying most people are saying
you need twenty five thousand pounds as
a deposit the government are saying save
up four grand a year and then put it
into a help to buy scheme and we'll give
you incentives but you have to live
there you can't do it as an investment
and the banks are saying we'll give you
money to get married we'll give you
money to go on holiday but we won't give
you money to invest in property because
that's risky we encourage you to buy now
pay later when it comes to liabilities
but lease option agreement everyone will
tell you lease option agreement risky
oh it's risky that what happens if the
house didn't go up you walk away long as
if you can't rent it out you have a
three-month break cloths and there's
come up with stuff because they don't
understand it and they're risk-averse
people but it's like how is it
acceptable to buy now pay later on a
holiday or a wedding or a car how is
that acceptable but you do it on a smart
strategic property investment it's
suddenly risky and your friends start
saying you know be careful be careful
it's crazy it's the same as when if I
mate in terrible and I'm eating that
McDonald's every day and I'm having to
snicker bars in bed with a beer no one
cares no there's anything but then you
start eating healthily people say be
careful don't go too skinny or you don't
eat enough meat you eat enough meat why
do you suddenly care so much and it's
the exact same your brokers heck with no
money and a job that you hate waking up
in the morning dreading going to work
with a wife or partner this
because of how little you're at home
because you're a slave right no one
cares
none says a word but then you say I'm
gonna learn how to invest in property
and I'm gonna I'm gonna get trained and
I'm gonna and the people say oh no no no
they be careful be careful be careful
geez we are broken minded messed up so
joint-venture how does that work two
people one person has knowledge skill
courage determination ability to
negotiate ability ability to find deals
they have time to view houses but they
have no money the other person has money
but nothing else
no courage no skills no time they've got
money sat in the bank doing nothing and
this person has got no money but they've
got everything else going for them and
this person says to this person hey how
about this here's a deal it needs fifty
grand
and then we need 20 grand to do a refurb
and then we pull all the money out my
suggestion is you put the money in I'll
do everything I'll project manage it off
I'll get the power team together I've
found the deal I'll oversee I'll do
everything and then we'll go fifty-fifty
on the profits what you're bringing to
the table as your joint venture partner
is you're putting the value you're
bringing is you're putting the money on
the value I'm bringing is everything
else and I think that the value is 5050
so we've got 50 on the profits that's
called a joint venture but who plays for
the legal agreements to be drawn up but
they do cuz their end of the bargain is
to put all of the money in your end of
the bargain is to do everything else
50/50 on the profits do that twice and
it's as if you making 100 percent of a
deal and you put no money in lack of
money is not your problem lack of
knowledge and lack of courage is your
problem so there's a few ways there's so
many more I mean you can control
properties instead of owning them you
can control them like Amazon doesn't own
its stock don't worry about owning
things but control everything
that's what Warren Buffett says don't
worry about owning things control
everything that's why you don't own the
taxis that are owned it but they control
everything
that's what Airbnb then I earn their
hotels massive company they control the
property in the same way you can do that
and honestly I've seen people do this
starting with nothing they've started
with that with their mom's house and
then rented it off their mom for a cheap
rent and then they've just rented the
rooms out on Airbnb and kept the profit
that's called controlling a property and
then taking it from general rent pushing
up the rent forcing the rent up at
getting super rent
keeping the cash flow in between pour
your sleeves up get creative and stop
making this stuff happen I've got to the
point in my in my business now whereby
I've built a large portfolio I'm still
doing big deals I'm doing
you can see I mean YouTube channel I put
in a YouTube video every single day on
property I got to the point now where
the money is great I love making money
it's awesome but the thing that gives me
more satisfaction than anything is the
significance that it gives me when you
become successful so I started working
class with nothing when you do the same
and when you get some success hunt me
down tell me I'll bring you on the
YouTube channel we can celebrate you get
money I get significance win-win that
can be add your adventure if you enjoyed
the video smash the like button we'll
see if you're not subscribed I'm putting
on a video on tomorrow and then guess
what the next day and the next day I'm
putting up videos every day you don't
want to miss them so turn the
notification about on because this stuff
isn't much better than your watch on the
TV so turn the notification about on
subscribe drop a nice comment and I'll
see you next time thanks so much
[Music]